[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get
weird and we search for the meaning of
life along the way
presented by cast media and soul
painting
[Applause]
[Music]
are there things that you are certain
you're right about that if you really
thought about it for more than a couple
of minutes you may think
maybe you're wrong i would love to say
yes
out of the uh generosity of my heart i
would love to say yes
i am open-minded about that but i'm
really not
like just when it when when you boil it
right down
i feel like i've read a lot of books
i've
studied a lot of belief systems
philosophies
religions i read a lot about politics
sociology psychology
yeah and i'm i'm pretty set in
that you earned your opinion i feel like
i've earned my opinion
yeah what about you do you have strong
opinions uh
no no no no no i'm you know i'm like a
reed in the wind i can go either way
not only do i have very strong opinions
one funny thing about me which my wife
uh
generously pointed out to me um
is that i will believe something to the
death
until it's proven wrong and then i will
believe the opposite of it
until the death so like whatever the
belief like i'm open to changing my mind
i'm not like one of these people who's
like i will not change my mind
it's just that the second i do change my
mind i'm just as
stubborn and like full of myself about
the new opinion as i was about the
previous
opinion but isn't this kind of a a
poison upon our land a pucks upon our
house
of america in 2021 that we
are so opinionated and we are so certain
and sure of our beliefs and our way of
seeing the world and how the world works
that we're not able to adapt and we are
getting
ever more stuck look there's something
to be said about this idea of
examining not just you know opinions
or ideas or certain facts that you've
been holding all along but maybe
even examining like values you know like
core beliefs that you have should those
things
which kind of define you as an
individual is that something
that you should look at again i mean
again
maybe you're wrong about it
maybe you and i are both wrong i mean
unlikely
unlikely to be sure but possible i i
think we need a guide
reza i think we need a guide in this
journey i know a guy
who's that adam grant obviously uh just
a you know world
famous rock star uh
business psychologist i guess he calls
he calls himself an organizational
psychologist which um i don't know what
that means
uh everybody knows who adam grant is his
first book give and take
was like gigantic success he wrote
originals how non-conformists move the
world
also a bestseller he wrote option b with
sheryl sandberg
that was a really really good book and
now now he's got this new
book which is precisely on this whole
issue right it's called think again
and the whole point of it is maybe
there are certain ideas
uh opinions even values that we have
both as individuals and as
collectives that uh that it's important
for us to
question and to and to kind of see if we
can poke holes in them and also maybe
uh part of that involves rethinking the
way that we
assume other people form their values
like how do we
kind of correct people that we disagree
with
right it's this idea of like relearning
and rethinking
and it's a fascinating book it's sure to
be another
gigantic success and i know this is
going to come as a shock to you rain
but we got him he's here he's here what
he's actually on the pod i know you had
no
preparation for this what's your name
adam grant whose ted talks have been
viewed more than 25 million times and
hosts the chart topping ted podcast work
life with adam grant who got his ba from
harvard and phd from the university of
michigan
how did you just happen to know all this
stuff about our guest
let's bring him on board adam grant come
on down
[Music]
adam grant welcome to metaphysical
milkshake thank you i'm
i'm excited to be here although i don't
think i've ever had metaphysics in a
milkshake before it
actually sounds kind of gross gross what
are you talking about gross it it tastes
like
chocolate chip cookies it is as good for
you as meatloaf
that's the problem i hate chocolate adam
obviously you are
a best known as an amateur magician
um what else do you do is there is that
it or
he's best known sure as an amateur
magician as a kid but also
a world-class all-american diver
as well so what wait i did not i've
known you for like
six seven years i didn't know that as a
diver yep he does have like a he does
have like that swimmer's head
right and jason also a world-class diver
was on the uh uk olympic team
same head yeah he's amazing i've i've
actually watched his 10 meter videos
and i used to want to be him when i grew
up you're almost there
so on the side i'm working on it you do
a little bit of writing and a little
academia and a little studying and a
little teaching
and we'd love to hear about your world
for those 27 listeners that don't know
uh too much about you
of our 29 we have 29 total listeners but
27 of them
probably have never heard of you tell us
a little bit about who you are
it's such a metaphysical question who
am i who was i yesterday who might i be
tomorrow i don't know
this is the least metaphysical question
i mean i it's funny i've been trying to
rethink my identity
i think if if you had asked me years ago
i would have said
i'm a diver i'm a magician uh i think
now
i i aspire to be a good person and
i think i don't know my definition of
being a good person has evolved
for for a while it was pursuing
excellence
now it's being generous and
trying to lead a life of integrity and
be a curious learner
and uh try to give people freedom and
opportunity
uh so i don't know is that is that too
metaphysical i love that and i love that
you're not defining yourself
as um well i'm a published author and
i'm a professor at wharton school of
business and i'm i've won these awards
um and defining yourself by
your excellence and your values and your
core belief about yourself i think
that's that's fantastic
and i think that ties in to uh the book
you wrote
and for those viewing on youtube i'm
going to hold it up for those listening
on podcasts i'm holding up the book
think again by adam grant
uh the power of knowing what you don't
know
uh what inspired you to write this book
i had so many
struggles with rethinking things um
i remember in middle school my best
friend uh we were on the phone it was a
commercial during seinfeld
and we got into an argument i have no
memory of what it was about
but he said shut up adam you're wrong
and i insisted i was right and he hung
up on me
and i tried to call him back and he said
i won't talk to you until you admit you
were wrong
and it was it was something that i was
very obviously wrong about i think it
was a movie quote and he had gone back
and watched the movie and i was clearly
wrong and i couldn't admit it
and i've gone through that experience so
many times in my life that eventually i
said okay
i have got to get better at rethinking
the things that i think i know
and also helping other people do do that
because that's that's sort of my job
right my job is to think again uh a lot
of the time as an organizational
psychologist it's about
how to make a job more meaningful and
motivating or a team more creative or a
culture more collaborative
but sometimes i don't practice what i
teach still
and i decided that this book would be a
great chance to turn research into
research and figure out
how i could become more open-minded and
how i could help other people do that
better too
yeah well i'm excited to dig deeper into
all the stuff that you talk about in the
book it's
a lot of fascinating stories in there
and a lot of
lessons about how to kind of question
some of our
uh basic assumptions and also how to you
know approach other people
who differ from you and in ways that
could
you know possibly change their minds as
well but
you know you tell the story about how
you knew you were wrong like rationally
you knew you were wrong but maybe
emotionally you refused to
admit that you were wrong by the way
this is an experience i know nothing
about
um what is that about what it
what is it about the human condition i
mean you've done an enormous amount of
work studying
sort of human psychology what is it
about us as individuals
that make it so difficult for us to just
simply say
maybe i'm wrong well i think i think the
the psychological part the emotional
part is
saying you're wrong at least in western
culture is saying
you're dumb right you're it's it's
calling your ques your intelligence or
your competence into question
and nobody wants to be unintelligent so
that's a risk
but then there's a social part of this
too which is if i admit i'm wrong
then not only are people going to think
i'm stupid they're also potentially
going to exclude me from the group
because they can't trust me anymore or
because i don't believe the things
that they believe anymore um and that's
that's
terrifying right evolutionarily
exclusion is is something that we had to
monitor
in order to survive and i think a lot of
social exclusion is not life-threatening
anymore but it still feels
life-threatening
uh so i think you know between your ego
and your belonging being on the line
that's a lot of pressure to face
well i'm glad you mentioned ego because
there was a section in your book that i
found fascinating about
the reaction that we have emotionally
deep down in our kind of reptilian brain
our amygdala
and uh there's a fight in flight kind of
response
sometimes to threat and that perceived
threat then gets kicked up
to kind of our our overarching ego and
you talk about that so
is that is it is it isn't it part of it
kind of
biological as well that to be right
means to kind of shore up who we are
because there is that perceived danger
yeah i think there's something there i i
love this term in psychology the
totalitarian ego
and for me it conjures up this image of
a miniature dictator living in
everyone's head and its job is to keep
out negative information about you the
same way that kim jong-un
controls the press in north korea and
that dictator is vigilant about saying
look anything that could be a threat
to your intelligence your attractiveness
your competence
i wanna i wanna shield you from that as
much as possible because it hurts
there are even some neuroscientists who
have shown that it's like being punched
in the mind
when when you're told you're wrong or
when your beliefs are your core beliefs
are challenged
um and so what do you do you put up
mental armor
and what i think is so interesting about
that armor is it protects you from pain
in the short term
but it also prevents you from growth in
the long term you end up spending all
this time trying to prove yourself
instead of actually working to improve
yourself
and i think we could use a little more
improving in the world and a little bit
less proving
so a lot of books like this are simply
think pieces one of the things i really
appreciate
about all of your writing and your talks
and and your work is
how can we personally apply it to
ourselves this isn't just in the realm
of academia
it has kind of personal not just
psychological but personal improvement
elements uh kind of woven in
and one of the things that really struck
home for me was a section you had at the
beginning of the book where you talked
about
the three different modes that people
like to get into
preacher mode prosecutor mode and
politician mode can you talk a little
bit about that and then i want to say
why i found that relevant credit to my
colleague phil tetlock for putting that
framework on the map the basic idea is
that we spend way too much time thinking
like preachers prosecutors and
politicians
so when you're in preacher mode you
believe you've already found the truth
and your job is to proselytize it
when you're in prosecutor mode you're
trying to win an argument and prove your
case
and when you're in politician mode
you're trying to win over an audience
and doing a lot of lobbying and
campaigning to get their approval
and my big worry was that preaching and
prosecuting stop us from thinking again
because you've already decided that i'm
right and everybody else is wrong so you
don't need to change your mind or
reconsider any of your views
and in politician mode you might be
telling your audience what you think
they want to hear
but you're probably not changing your
views deep down right you're sticking to
your tribe
and i i find this super interesting as
an organizational psychologist because
i've never worked in any of those jobs
right i'm i'm not a preacher i'm not i'm
not really religious
i didn't go to law school no prosecuting
experience and i hate politics
and yet i catch myself slipping into
these modes from time to time and i
think they really cloud my judgment and
my thinking
metaphysical milkshakers listeners all
have you ever had one of those ideas
that you just don't know how to get
started on making it into a reality
totally
experts say that not knowing how or
where to start is one of the biggest
causes
of procrastination this is where the
blinkist app
comes in blinkist takes top non-fiction
books pulls out the key takeaways puts
them into text
and audio explainers called blinks use
blinks to learn about how to tackle
procrastination
or to get started on developing a
business idea
or to just take your projects one step
further the great thing about it is that
blinkist
has like thousands of titles in like 27
categories
all ready to learn a lot of stuff on
race
which is great there's been you know a
renewed interest in conversations about
it
why i'm no longer talking to white
people about race uh how to be an
anti-racist
white fragility skin in the game that's
a good one yeah i don't know if you've
read uh
from black lives matter to black
liberation it's a good one
right now folks blinkist has a special
offer
just for our audience go to blinkist.com
milkshake to start your free seven-day
trial and get 25
off a blinkist premium membership that's
blinkist spelled b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
blinkist dot com slash milkshake 25 off
and a seven-day free trial
blinkus.com slash what milkshake
milkshake it is you know these days
many small business owners are busier
than ever of course they are because
they're focused on managing and growing
their businesses
so they can't always spend the time they
wish they could on recruiting and that's
why
linkedin jobs has made it easier to find
and hire the best candidates for
free rain you've hired people i've hired
people
and let me tell you you want to
definitely
do background checks on these people and
want the right kind of recommendations
the right kind of resume
super important who you hire and that's
why linkedin
can help you can get started by posting
your job for free
and you can reach linkedin's gigantic
network 740
million professionals everybody's on
linkedin reza you can fill out
targeted screening questions so you can
get your role in front of the most
qualified candidates with the experience
skills and motivation
you need and then you just use these
simple tools to filter and prioritize
the top candidates you'd like to
interview
so linkedin jobs will help you hire the
right person for your role
and your first job post is free just
visit linkedin.com
milkshake again that's linkedin.com
milkshake in order to do what to post
your first
job for free terms and conditions apply
and you know you and i have had a number
of conversations
along these lines so you probably
already know that i had some problems
with your book which is that yeah look i
mean
it's important to rethink certain
assumptions and hypotheses and theories
that you have but it seems as though
you're suggesting that values and mores
are also things that require rethinking
it's one thing to be like
uh maybe there is life underneath the
ice
on the frozen moon of europa
and i'm gonna hypothesize that and see
if i can prove it and be open to the
fact that it may not be provable
it's another thing to be like all human
beings are created equal regardless of
the color of their skin
or their you know the the who they
happen to love or how they
define their gender and
disagreeing with that is not just an
alternative
idea or an opposing opinion it's [ __ ]
wrong
there's nothing right about it so
i guess that's that's where i kind of
get caught a little bit you say you say
in there
you don't have to believe everything you
think
and i think i understand what that means
but i want to i want to be clearer
but then later on you say who you are
should be a question of what you value
not what you believe
so i i i need i need some help kind of
reconciling those two points
and figuring out at what point can i
simply say no i don't need
to rethink certain of my assumptions
i just want to say you're in prosecutor
mode bro
and i love it i was gonna say the same
thing also can i get an amen
reza in prosecutor mode you're really at
your finest in that mode
no i i actually think this this is
something i really struggled with in the
book on two levels
one is i think sometimes that when
you're thinking like a scientist you
sound like a prosecutor
because you're trying to subject
somebody else's unscientific thinking to
critical scrutiny
and i i think we need more of that in
the world and that's that's why i am
proud that my biggest advice of
preaching prosecuting and politicking is
also prosecuting
uh when when i hear an idea that i think
is wrong i just feel like it's my moral
responsibility to correct it with
sharper logic and stronger evidence
and so i'm i'm very glad to be the
target of that maybe even the victim of
it
uh so reza i to the the substance of
your critique
this is really something i struggled
with in the book i wanted to build a
hierarchy of things that we
should be quicker to abandon and and
much
uh much more consistent around um and
i didn't end up doing it and i regret it
so i would have started by saying okay
opinions and assumptions and intuitions
should be at the very bottom
in terms of we should be as flexible as
possible with those right those are all
just hypotheses
and then as we move to core beliefs we
should be a little bit
a little bit less willing to just let
them go tomorrow
although i also think it's it gets more
dangerous to hang on to
to false beliefs right and so i don't
want people to be inflexible there
and then at the very top i would have
put values and principles
and said okay you shouldn't abandon some
of your core principles
i don't want to go down like a too long
of a rabbit hole and rain and i have yes
you do these arguments yes you do
you want to prosecute yeah it's just it
is
true that some values are better than
others that's just true wait wait hold
on says who
and for what outcomes so so again this
this is the difference between a
psychologist and a sociologist right
which is that to me it's all it's not
about the individual
it's about the betterment of society and
civilization
and there are certain rules
to the game of society and civilization
one of the foundational rules is that we
all are equal
we are we all have equal access we're
all
equally human and so if you violate that
rule
in other words if your core value is the
dehumanization
of another because of the color of their
skin or who they worship or who they
love
then you're not you're not you don't get
to play the game but wait a minute
reza you the core values
of humanity up until about 1962
and martin luther king the core values
of humanity
was complete and blatant inequality
and that's the foundation of
civilization not just western
civilization
all of civilization had slaves and
denigrated women and uh so how can you
say like
these are the core values that if you
don't play by these rules you can't even
play the game
that's how we got here okay so who
between um uh you know uh
george wallace and martin luther king
who was right one of them was wrong
and it's not an issue of like well i
think both of them should have really
looked deep down inside and
and questioned their fundamental
assumptions about
humanity there are some things that are
just wrong there are opinions that are
just
plain wrong science deniers fake news
uh spreaders conspiracy theorists
so i think that that it's worth asking
someone like adam um what is
what actually is the value what is the
the point of trying to
sort of reach out to to people who hold
uh views that are just plain wrong
and trying to you know change their
minds right when they don't even accept
the rules of the game
let me respond to two pieces of that the
first one is i think there's a
difference between factually wrong and
morally wrong
but i could actually say we could think
like a
like a scientist about both right so you
say all right there are some rules
that are going to lead to a better
society
right whether we're talking about a
democratic society or a peaceful
civilization right we could we could
think about what exactly a good society
means
and we should probably look to actual
philosophers to help us do that right
because
this is what they do for a living and
then once we agree on on what social
good looks like we can start to measure
that and we can say look we could we
could gather data
we can run the experiments we can track
longitudinally what happens when these
moral principles are adopted
and i i you know i've spent my career
doing a version of this at a much lower
level of analysis which is studying
individuals and groups
and finding that it's possible to align
what you and i would consider to be
virtues
right moral values um like generosity
and humility
with achieving success uh when you know
when you think about a performance goal
and i don't think it would be difficult
to do the same thing right at
a larger scale and i know there are
multiple fields that have tried to do
this so
i i i just love the idea that we can use
evidence to support the moral argument
and say actually there's there's a
scientific case
to uh to follow these moral principles
because if you value peace if you value
prosperity
if you value opportunity and freedom for
everyone then you know
there's data there are data that would
tell us that's a that's a good way to go
now uh to the the question of should i
try to open the minds of people who
don't even buy into
you know the the standards of fact and
evidence
i guess what i want to know is what's
the alternative letting them continue to
believe in conspiracy theories
and continue to peddle fake news and
continue to
foment insurrections that sounds like a
much worse outcome to me
than trying to engage those people and
open their minds i've brought up this
example
a long time ago on an earlier podcast we
did but i was really struck by this
article it was in the new york times
and it was uh when trump was running for
office and talking about build the wall
and talking about
uh dangerous immigrants coming over and
gangs and spreading disease and their
murders and rapists coming over
and they interviewed some people in
mid-america about this who agreed with
that
and then they started showing them
pictures of um
latinx families that were coming over or
had come over and
here's this girl and her name is lupe
and she went to college and she's got a
job and she's participating and she's so
happy to be an american they're like oh
she should be able to stay like and
here's you know
gustavo and he came over and he got a
job and he put his children into school
and
he's now working as a successful
automobile mechanic oh he should be able
to come
like when the stories got personal when
they saw pictures and they saw faces
their hearts kind of opened and melted
in a way so is there a
is there we've been speaking very
intellectually about this stuff and
talking about being scientists which
for me is like you should be more like
spock
but isn't there why can't we think more
like
a tibetan monk why can't we think more
like a poet
or think more like uh a great therapist
uh in in in connecting with people in
changing our minds and and allowing
other people's minds to change
i think that's a brilliant question i
think i think we need
more of all of those professions in our
heads
and you know it reminds me it reminds me
sorry i have to go to the data because
that's what i do as a social scientist
but uh there's a meta-analysis a study
of studies
looking at intergroup contact
interventions where you actually come
face to face with somebody who belongs
to the group that you're prejudiced
against
and you know it sounds like one of those
too good to be true ideas that if only
we could sit down face to face and talk
to each other
we would all get along and yet over 700
studies
in 94 of the cases intergroup contact
reduces prejudice wow
and one of the most extraordinary
demonstrations was just published last
year from the seeds of peace camp
that takes teenagers from israel and
palestine
and has them come come together at
summer camp
and it turns out that if you just happen
to be assigned to
a bunk with somebody from the other
country
that you're i think roughly in the data
11 times more likely
to develop a close friendship with them
afterward
and that if you happen to be in a
discussion group with somebody from your
rival country
i think you're 15 times more likely than
to
develop a real lasting friendship with
somebody you know who you thought was
your enemy
and it really it really just reinforces
that when
when you spend time interacting with
someone when you hear their story
uh when you're able to empathize with
them all of a sudden you realize there
is more to a person
than a belief they hold or a group that
they belong to yeah absolutely so one
question that i have which i don't think
was really covered in your books it was
all about sort of
individuals and changing one's own minds
changing other people's minds things
like that
i wonder is there like a collective
belief
that we have about america that you
think
needs to be rethought so many i have i
mean i have mine i have one that i
i have but i want to hear what's yours
mine uh
well if i i mean if i say it they might
kick me out so why don't you say yours
first
and then i'll say mine there's a long
list for me i think
one of the most basic ones is that
america is a land of opportunity
that we live in a meritocracy which is
just a joke just absolute [ __ ]
i i want to say it couldn't be less true
except to know that there are countries
where it's less true
mine is kind of like that mine is the
the whole theory of american
exceptionalism
which is you know something that i was
fed and that i used to even regurgitate
all the time this idea that there's
something exceptional
about this country that there's no other
country in the world like it that we are
the greatest country
in the world which you know to your
point adam of like
actually thinking like a scientist is
like objectively demonstrably false
i mean there's like as far as i know not
a single
rubric in which we are uh
number one except for i think military
spending and
also um the economic disparity i think
that those are our two
biggest those that's where we're number
one but it's just like such
such a foundational idea that even now
i still find myself having to kind of
correct it when the thought occurs to me
there are
there are multiple cases to be made that
we are the most individualistic country
on earth
right and i i got curious about how we
got that way and one of one of the most
interesting arguments i've read is
if you look at who was willing to get in
a boat and sail to
just complete uncertainty it was a bunch
of
extroverted narcissistic individualistic
people
who had the audacity to believe i'm
gonna make it and we can make a new
country
uh and you know a lot of people just
weren't up for the voyage and you know
then you could raise a question about
okay did that
you know did that give us a certain
genetic density or a certain
you know set of of cultural pressures
that tipped us in that direction
whatever happened now that we're here
i think that it's a false dichotomy to
separate individualism
from uh from community i think that in
some ways america has always been a
community-oriented place
uh de tocqueville when he came here
right marveled at how philanthropic we
were how much we volunteered
we still i think are the this is another
maybe rare dimension of american
exceptionalism
right if you look at our rates of
financial giving and volunteering time
uh we are pretty much in a league of
legends we're far and away the most
charitable country
in the world and when there's national
disas international disasters
it's always the united states and not
just because of our wealth it's like per
capita even people making under 60 000
a year giving larger percentages of
their income towards philanthropy
yeah and then we could we could debate
about why that is too and
say well you know we also see that the
conservatives are more philanthropic
than you know than liberals are um and
arthur brooks has shown that's in part
because
liberals sort of believe it's the
government's responsibility uh and
conservatives take it upon themselves
more often but
wherever that comes from i think we
could recognize that you can be
individualistic and community oriented
at the same time right it's possible to
fit in
and stand out um there's a term for that
in social psychology it's called optimal
distinctiveness
and it is the sense that that you
both have status and you also have
belonging
and i think this is where we run into
trouble that
um there's a social psychologist marilyn
brewer who's shown that we seek out
optimal distinctiveness
by affiliating and identifying with with
unusual groups
and that way we belong to something
but it's really different from anything
else that exists
and i think that's where our tribalism
gets us in trouble so
i don't know i think this is a hard
problem to solve i think that
probably some superordinate identity is
helpful right trying to lift us up to
thinking about what are the
quintessentially american values
uh like freedom from oppression uh like
opportunity for all
uh i think that could be a starting
point uh i think
you know recognizing that you can you
can have status as an individual
and that doesn't mean you can't also be
reliant
on your community or on your family
would be a big help right to rebrand
help seeking as a source of strength not
a sign of weakness
might do us some good i don't know what
do you both think i think you nailed it
and i think you brought up uh
some incredibly valuable and salient
points and i love that i here's a way in
which my mind
was changed adam i didn't think about
individualism versus community in a
terms of a false dichotomy and you're
right it is a false dichotomy
one can be extremely individualistic one
can be in a community of extreme
individuals um and we
can learn how to do that we can learn
how to live free or die
and make sure that our community is
living
free or dying wait that didn't really
come out right but you know what
you know what i'm saying so that i was i
allowed my mind to be changed by this
conversation thank you adam oh there you
go
there you forced brain to think again i
i hope i invited him not forced
[Music]
rain uh you're you're a cbd fan right
cbd can be very helpful it's not about
what you feel
it's about what you don't feel oh good
way of cbd
yeah you don't feel stressed you don't
feel anxiety you don't feel
pain sometimes i have trouble sleeping
and i took some
a couple hours before bed and man i just
got chill
in a really cool way and i was able to
sleep
really deeply it actually helped it's a
premium cbd
it helps keep your head clear and it
helps you feel your best it's hassle
free
it's delivered directly to your door you
know cbd
not only helps you sleep like you just
said but it reduces stress it reduces
anxiety and pain
and no hangover no addiction so
place a few drops of fields under your
tongue and feel the difference within
minutes joining the feels monthly
membership makes your self-care easy
you'll save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel at any time so start
feeling better with feels
become a member today by going to
feels.com
milkshake and you'll get 50 off your
first order
with free shipping that's f e a l s dot
com
slash milkshake to become a member and
get 50 automatically taken off your
first order
with free shipping feels dot com slash
milkshake ryan what was the last time
that you had cereal i mean honest to
goodness like cereal in a box
i gotta be honest with you sometimes
when i'm eating my emotions i go
straight for the box
of my son's cereal this is the thing is
like you get magic spoon and you don't
have to feel
bad about eating kids cereal anymore
because we're all trying to eat better
we're plugging a lot of stuff on the
show but legit
you reza you love the magic spoon i'm
not gonna lie here
i love magic spoon we got four boxes of
cereal
uh in the mail it lasted i don't know 24
hours maybe we all sat around as a giant
family and just like
scarfed it down magic spoons got zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
that's incredible you go to
magicspoon.com
milkshake to grab a variety pack and
then you can try today and be sure to
use our promo code
milkshake you save five bucks off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you're some kind of weirdo who
doesn't like
cereal then don't worry you can
return it for any reason they'll refund
your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
milkshake use that code folks milkshake
to save five dollars off thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
and please send my family more cereal
send us more magic spoon
now we are going to prosecute you with
what we call our
lightning round please give us the first
answer that comes on the tip of your
tongue
speak from your heart speak from your
gut what recharges your soul
being inspired by brilliant motivated
students when do you feel most connected
with the universe
when i'm completely absorbed in reading
a book and i forget
that the story i'm reading is not real
what's the silliest fear you have
i'm afraid that somebody is gonna plant
an m
m in my bag of skittles i hate chocolate
that much
wow it happened to me once and i i now
have ptsd around it apparently
when do you truly feel like yourself
when i'm writing when i'm reading uh
when i'm
obsessed with pursuing a goal and when
i'm talking to somebody
who i respect and care about what's one
eye-opening experience
every person should have standing in a
red circle and giving a ted talk
how do you think you will die i hope i
won't
you want you want to live forever that's
the brain in a jar
i mean i i'm hoping we have better
technology by then but
better it's better than not being alive
i think
that's just ridiculous i'm sorry
but i'm gonna let it go i don't find it
ridiculous at all
i think the alternatives are ridiculous
i mean existing is better than not
existing
full stop well you're you're assuming
that with death comes non-existence
so that's a very big assessment that's a
different episode
it is and i'm just saying i have a lot
of questions that science can't help me
answer there and so
i prefer the the certain existence over
the
uncertainty around non-existence what
book has had the biggest impact on your
life
and why one of the ones that that was
pivotal was tuesdays with mori
i read that book and i realized that the
people who'd had the biggest impact on
my life
were my teachers and suddenly i wanted
to pay that forward
besides your irrational fear of m m's
what's one thing
that people don't know about you i once
took a bus from
boston to mexico city and back just for
fun
i had no exams my senior uh
january all my friends were studying for
four weeks
and i had just enough money to afford a
bus ticket and it was
i think 58 hours to to get to
monterey maybe and then i don't know i
spent a couple hundred hours traveling
around my bus and then back i will never
do that again
[Laughter]
that's fantastic we know you're a
magician we know that you're an expert
diver
and you're okay at writing books in
teaching classes but what's one skill
you wish you had comedy
what is your life's big question how can
we help people care more about building
character
than pursuing happiness that's beautiful
adam grant this has
just been a sincere and profound
pleasure and uh
i got so much out of reading your book
and i'm wanting to know
how you got m night shimalyan to quote
your book
it's shyamalan shyamalan thank you
um i asked him i texted knight and he
responded and said he would be happy to
do it
the blurb people should know you can't
see the book here the blurb says
it turns out adam was dead the whole the
whole time
the whole time shhh
don't spoil it spoiler alert adam grant
you're a great thinker a great teacher a
great writer a great friend
it was wonderful to talk to you thank
you so much for coming on the pod
this was a ton of fun i could definitely
do it all day i
can't wait to turn the tables
anytime anytime
adam is always so fascinating isn't he
he's such a nice guy too
he is so nice and he has such an
encyclopedic
knowledge of statistics and studies he
can just conjure up anything
you know what's one skill i wish i had i
wish i had that skill that's that's
pretty amazing
and also you know i he really he really
did kind of
change your mind there at the end like
that was you know the whole like
individualism versus communalism which i
also
i have to say like it's a it's kind of a
belief that i have it's something i've
written about a lot about western
society being more individualistic and
eastern society being more communal but
like he uh he kind of challenged that
that dichotomy for you didn't he
yeah he did and it really was a light
bulb moment because i have been
vigorously and vehemently arguing um
that we're too individualistic and we've
got to be
more communalistic community orient
oriented
more you know collaborative and
to see that wait a second those two
forces are not necessarily in opposition
it's not one or the other
it is possible to have both kind of
wedded in a unique american
identity and that's that
it stopped me in my tracks quite
honestly and it's it's something
really worth looking at and pondering
some more
and um and it might even be a way of
helping kind of bridge this great divide
we have in our country
is to say hey guys it's not just
individualism and liberty
and it's not just collectivism and
equaling socialism big air quotes there
but how can we merge the two and
find uh a union of of those two
forces yeah i was thinking like is there
a belief
that i hold right now yeah
that i have that i am confident in its
truth or validity that
you know going by adam's point
i'd be willing to rethink re-examine
things that i may possibly be wrong
about anything come to mind um
if you don't have one i've got one for
you
tell me what i should re-examine about
my beliefs tell me
i'm going to prosecute you all right
prosecutors
get away so you have a belief that comes
up sometimes like you're a very
big-hearted person and a devoted family
man
and incredibly compassionate to all
people on earth
but you have uh a certain set of beliefs
around
kind of coalition building between
the uh political right and political
left
in the united states that you think is
just
poppycock and nonsense that we should
not be reaching hands across the aisle
building coalitions coming together
finding common ground
that uh that we should um
i don't know uh no that the right is a
cancer uh
and that it needs to be excised from the
body politic
before it metastasizes and spreads and
kills
us all there you have it america so is
that a belief that you would be willing
to look at a little bit yeah you know
this is a really fascinating
question because a few years ago five
five six years ago
i was definitely a you know reach across
the aisle
person so in a way my mind was changed
from
that that it's worth reaching across the
aisle
and then i discovered that a good half
of this country
hates me and my children um
and you know openly supports
you know uh xenophobia and
uh racism and you know and all and all
of that stuff and that really i think
that
that was such a eye-opening experience
for me
that i was like huh
yeah you know what [ __ ] those guys um
so i feel like i could you know we're
given some time
and and some thought and some sort of
general progress in american society i
could definitely go back to the way that
i used to think
i could i yeah yeah i'm going to get you
there i'm going to coax you there
and metaphysical milkshake can be the
olive branch
you know as a matter of fact we got a
really interesting
voicemail uh about this question what if
i'm wrong from one of our listeners uh
named nicolette let's listen to that
voicemail real quick
i think it's really hard to change your
mind because the mind
is something that i think we use to what
we
consider is to protect ourselves so if
you have the answers if you know what
you think and feel about everything
then you know you don't have to
wonder and you don't have to question
and it's sort of this little cocoon that
you feel safe in which is not a cocoon
that you should be saving so i like to
say i suspend my disbeliefs
so then i don't have to change my mind
because i don't just believe anything
i love that phrase to spend your
disbeliefs
i think there's there's really something
there and i you know i like that concept
too
uh which is kind of essentially i feel
like what she's saying is a
made-up mind is an offensive defense
mechanism yeah and she's right that
there is something safe
and secure about having you know like
these solid beliefs that
you hold on to for dear life whether
they're right or not
doesn't really matter right yeah yeah
well you know interestingly enough uh
we were so intrigued by this particular
uh
voicemail that um we hired a private
investigator
uh cast media of course paid for all of
that
uh to track her down and we found her
and we actually have her here to talk to
us nicolette are you there
hi nicolette hey
glad to be here thanks for for calling
in that terrific uh
answer to our metaphysical life's big
question there
now am i am i wrong here are you guys
related somehow
we're related nicolette is my
mother oh my god no
wayne don't don't put me that old please
no but there is a connection you you
knew some of my family is that right
i used to go to children's classes at
your stepmother christie's uh parents
house
yeah doug and betty harris in seattle
and did you learn anything at those
children's classes
i did i learned more than i've ever
learned in my whole life
because i think i learned from an
emotional place
versus an intellectual place you know
the mind
protects us as a child you're you're
open to
you know you don't you're open with your
heart
right there and then and that is a good
analogy to to kind of look at
the child mind versus in buddhism they
call it like the beginner's mind
versus kind of the made-up mind the set
mind the kind of like
set in its tracks mind but
so do you do you feel like you have an
open mind like can your mind be
changed yes my mind is open to be
changed
my heart probably not hmm
how do you how do you tell the
difference between the two is what i'm
curious about because i don't know if i
can tell the difference really between
my mind and my heart
can i tell a story tell the story we
love stories around
okay i was engaged once and
uh he was a vietnam vet and he had some
problems
with uh vietnam and ptsd
so we went to a counselor and the
counselor asked us both if we wanted to
work on the relationship
and i was by that time i was really kind
of tired and i was just like yeah
you know had it tried all read about
ptsd did everything
but so i really wanted to give him a
real
honest heartfelt answers so i could feel
my mind said no but my heart and my gut
felt yes and that was probably the first
time i've ever felt the delineation
between my mind my heart my gut
there's something about what you're
saying nicolette that is so fascinating
which is that
this idea that part of the reason
why we have such a hard time admitting
when we're wrong or being open to
changing our mind
about something is that there's a lot of
like
comfort and security and safety
and well-being in the idea of certainty
right that we hold these notions in our
in our mind and we we find sustenance in
them we find
comfort in them and then somebody shows
up and when they tell you that you
you may be wrong about it we don't we
don't hear it as
oh this aspect of your thought process
on this particular topic or this
particular subject may not be
well thought out there may be another
way of looking at it what we hear
is that you're not safe anymore you're
not secure anymore you're not
comfortable
anymore it feels like an attack you know
i like your idea that just never have
anything
that's you know fully certain in your
mind and then that'll never actually
happen
but i like the way that nicolette
brought up the mind heart
connection i don't want to say dichotomy
connection
because for me sometimes my mind can get
made up pretty quickly and i'll read a
news article and i'll kind of like oh
this
that's [ __ ] and this is how it is
and this is how it should be and i turn
into a kind of a grumpy old white man
and then and then if i interact
with the story in a way that touches my
heart it kind of thaws my mind and i'm
like
oh you know it's like through compassion
you know the veils can kind of drop and
i can say
you know maybe i should reconsider that
like a softer heart
leads to a softer mind so your heart can
change your mind
i like that what do you think nicolette
well rain you know
that as an actor you're never supposed
to play a character
bad you're supposed to find the
motivation for why they do
what they do so if you if you
can do that in your own if people can do
that in their own personal lives
if they can understand where motivations
come from
i think that then will also um
help them be more compassionate yeah so
increasing compassion that definitely
the only problem with that analogy
nicolette is i'm not
really a very good actor i'm just like
how can i play this big weird character
you know maybe i'll make give myself a
funny haircut boom
that's kind of how i work so you know
you're not talking to matt damon here
okay well nicole this has been an
excellent way
to uh close this topic thank you so much
uh
for talking to us it was a sincere
pleasure i'll say hi
to kristen my stepmom from you
and uh wishing you much love thanks for
joining the show nicolette
youtube thank you thank you follow us
metaphysical milkshake
on apple podcasts or spotify or wherever
you happen to get
your fine podcasts yeah if you want more
of life's
big questions you can find us on our
socials at reza aslan
at rayne wilson and of course at
metaphysical milkshake and on twitter
we're
at meta milk podcast let us know your
life's big
questions the things that are going
through your mind maybe topics that you
would like us to
cover we just might do that hit hashtag
metaphysical and please
review us on these sites that would
really help
grow our listenership and we would
appreciate it so so much
that's right either on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen to podcasts
and of course you can also subscribe to
the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel and watch full episodes
every week you can watch our faces move
while we have these conversations
some of our faces move more than others
but you know yes
i don't even know what that means thanks
for listening folks think again
see you next week
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold and
audio mixed by justin kyle original
music is composed by jeff tank
maybe it's opinion right that might have
made sense in 1995 but the same way that
you laugh at somebody
who is still using windows 95 on their
computer maybe we should
laugh at our our old selves that held
1995 views he's talking about you wayne
oh i mean i don't know am i
[Music]
uh maybe a little bit yeah i mean i i
still think grunge is the best music
ever created so
i mean you should see his collection of
flannel shirts it's
it's really it's obscene